en ce qui concerne la russie la russie
quant à elle est présentée comme une
menace difficile or c'est une
c'est du reste du sénat d'entretenir ce
dialogue vous le savez travers les deux
rapports que nous avons réalisé nous ne
sommes pas dupes nous ne sommes pas
innocent mais nous considérons qu aucune
crise à l'heure actuelle notamment celle
qui secoue lorient le levant et l'europe
centrale ne peut ne peuvent être réglés
sans la présence de la russie et c'est
ce pourquoi il nous apparaît et je crois
être en conformité avec les engagements
et les directions que le président de la
république avait pris notamment au
lendemain des entretiens de brégançon
qu'un dialogue avec la russie sont
maintenus en tous les cas c'est ce que
nous faisons
vous nous direz là aussi quel est le
point d'actualité de cette relation
franco-russe dont dont nous mesurons
aussi la difficulté notamment à la
faveur des derniers événements touchant
un opposant dont le monde entier a parlé
toujours dans cette revue stratégique
qui nous apparaît que l'optimisme
européen qui était déjà un point central
de réal paiement 2018 nous apparaît de
plus en plus en décalage avec la réalité
telle que nous la vivons nous venons
d'avoir trois auditions permettant
discuter de la coopération franco
allemande dans le domaine capacitaire
nous avons reçu la semaine dernière le
président de dassault nous nous
entretenions ce matin avec monsieur dire
qu'au quai antoine
antoine bouvier et
et nous aurons prochainement le dg a
mais nous voyons bien que au delà des
affirmations de principe il ya encore
nombre de difficultés qui mérite d'être
étudiée éclaircies et à ceux là se
surajoute les hypothèques politique
représente la situation politique en
allemagne ici nous en juge par les
réseaux et les élections récentes qui
viennent d'avoir lieu dimanche dernier
dans des états importants et les
commentaires y compris en allemagne qui
sont faits à ce sujet on ne naît pas
tout à fait sûr de la manière dont la
situation politique va se stabiliser à
l'issue des élections prochaines
de la même manière cette situation dans
le domaine qui nous concerne plus
directement qui est cette coopération
dans le domaine capacitaire la situation
nous interpelle et je l'imaginé vous
aussi madame la ministre
quelle explication donnez-vous à ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier de
l'accumulation des difficultés
le scav bien sûr le mgc s le tigre mark
iii l'euro drones male le programme most
et on en vient à se demander si le pari
allemand du président de la république
que nous avons soutenu n'est pas en
passe d'être perdus et si véritablement
comme le suggère une tribune aujourd'hui
dans le figaro
les allemands sont vraiment demandeurs
de cette coopération européenne
je ne préfère pas plutôt l'assurance
américaine et ces exemples montrent
précisément que la situation stratégique
a considérablement évolué en 4 années et
donc vous aurez l'occasion de nous
donner votre sentiment
alors bien évidemment comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure la revue stratégique est
une étape mais le fond du sujet c'est
évidemment la loi de programmation
militaire
lorsque je pense que vous en souvenez
lorsque nous avons débattu de la lpm en
je vous avais dit aidez-nous madame la
ministre
aidez nous à vous aider et bon ce n'est
pas vous qui est en cause parce que je
pense que vous étiez à titre personnel
vous aviez je crois savoir que vous
aviez plutôt plaidé peau une oie
d'actualisation ce n'est pas le choix
qui a été fait par le gouvernement on le
respecte c'est un choix qui a été fait
et nous aurions préféré avoir une loi de
l'actualisation qui était du reste
inscrite dans le texte
et je rappelle que cet lp m nous
l'avions voté au sénat à 3 95 % 1 ce qui
était aussi une manière de de
réassurance en quelque sorte du
parlement non pas face à des menaces à
l'intérieur même d'une liste r bien sûr
mais plutôt nous étions toujours nous
sommes toujours attentifs
l'attitude du de bercy qui dans la
situation budgétaire actuelle pourrait
être tenté de revoir des engagements sur
lequel le président de la république
s'est pourtant constamment prononcée est
donc bon voilà le parlement se sent un
peu à l'écart vous le savez c'est un peu
le sentiment aussi que nos collègues
députés ont partagé avec nous et on
aimerait pouvoir vous aider dans cet
effort de défense que vous avez conduit
moi je souhaite vraiment ici vous rendre
hommage parce que nous l'avons dit à
chaque exercice budgétaire nous avons
vécu trois exercices budgétaires à
chaque fois à l'euro près les
engagements ont été tenus mais nous
savons bien que maintenant les marches
deviennent un peu plus hautes et
l'escalier un peu plus raide puisque les
dernières marches y compris celles qui
seront tous au delà de 2022 sont peu
prévu de l'ordre de 3 milliards par an
donc voilà pourquoi nous avons considéré
qu'il était indispensable de lancer une
mission d'information sur
l'actualisation de la loi de
programmation militaire et j'ai cru
comprendre dans l' enveloppe que vous
venez de me remettre qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de réponses qui est et
qui j'espère correspondront un peu plus
aux attentes par rapport à la première
livraison que vous nous adressez nous ne
rapporteur peut-être aurons l'occasion
de revenir sur ce sujet et donc madame
la ministre au moment où vous travaillez
sur les arbitrages de la programmation
militaire dans le processus d' adopter m
serre l'ajustement annuel de la
progression de la programmation
militaire
ce que l'on attend d'eux vous bien
évidemment c'est la plus grande clarté
la plus grande transparence encore une
fois il n'y a aucune volonté de la part
de la commission de mettre le
gouvernement en difficulté on veut
simplement savoir si l' actualisation de
la loi de programmation militaire qui
nous semble nécessaire car je les dis
léger les menaces ont évolué des
nouvelles priorités apparaissent
la crise pandémique qui a qui est en
train de mettre à mal les finances
publiques a des conséquences bien
évidemment ne serait ce que par le
rétrécissement du produit national brut
qui a donc des conséquences tout ceci
est important est important et nous
sommes prêts à le prendre en compte
mais ce que l'on veut c'est que
vis-à-vis du parlement qui est juste
dans son rôle d'évaluation et de
contrôle
eh bien ils puissent en nous puissions
avoir les éléments qui nous permettent
de remplir notre mission voilà donc
pourquoi je vous propose de faire à la
fois le point sur l'actualisation de la
revue stratégique et de profiter de
votre présence pour engager le dialogue
sur l'actualisation de la lpm dialogue
qui a été souhaité par le président de
la république car nous étions dans le
froid et dans le vent à brest au veut
désormais le président de la république
a précisément dit qu'il souhaitait que
cette actualisation puisse intervenir en
liaison avec le parlement et donc nous
sommes là dans notre rôle je vous
rappelle que cette audition ait capté
qu'elle est diffusée sur le site du
sénat
et je vous propose donc de nous en avons
la tradition et l'habitude de prendre la
parole pendant le temps que vous
souhaitez puis après nous aurons un
échange avec nos collègues non seulement
ceux qui sont ici mais ce que je vois à
l'écran il comprit nous votre ami
devienne enfin nous avons des toutes
sortes de collègues qui sont là et qui
se rendent disponibles pour vous
entendre madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
tout d'abord merci de m'accueillir
aujourd'hui pour dresser le panorama de
de notre environnement stratégique comme
vous le savez à son élection le
président république avait souhaité
procéder à une actualisation en quelque
sorte du livre blanc c'était la revue
stratégique de 2017 avec un objectif
mener une analyse fine et et complète de
la situation stratégique internationale
pour pouvoir en tirer les conséquences
pour notre défense
alors face à un monde totalement
bouleversé par la crise sanitaire
il nous a semblé indispensable de
procéder à une actualisation une
nouvelle analyse des menaces qui se
posent à nous cette man d'amy a été
particulièrement révélatrice de
l'incertitude et de l'imprévisibilité de
l'environnement dans lequel nous
évoluons et le travail d'actualisation
qui a été conduit a mis en lumière la
persistance des menaces que nous avions
identifiés en 2017 et dans certains
domaines il s'agit plus que d'une
persistance c'est même un renforcement
voir une accélération de ces tendances
que nous pouvons observer actuellement
je pense en particulier au délitement de
l'ordre international à l'effritement du
multilatéralisme
tout ceci se traduisant par un repli sur
soi dangereux et par l'affirmation de
logique de puissance
alors comme nous l'avions déjà
identifiés en 2010 est la première
menace à laquelle nous sommes confrontés
et contre laquelle nous devons lutter
c'est le terrorisme sur le territoire
national comme à l'étranger
ils menacent la sécurité des français
ainsi que nos intérêts nationaux nous le
combattons au levant au sahel ainsi que
sur notre propre sol
nous sommes militairement engagés pour
empêcher que ne s'implantent un arc
djihadistes du golfe de guinée jusqu'au
théâtre irak aux syriens qui serait en
mesure de projeter des attentats jusque
sur notre territoire national la
déstabilisation du monde que nous vivons
est aussi due à l'émergence de nouveaux
espaces de confrontation aussi bien le
cyberespace et la maîtrise de
l'information que les fonds sous marins
ainsi que l'espace exo atmosphérique qui
est devenu indispensable à la conduite
de nos opérations et où certaines
puissances réalisent déjà des manoeuvres
stratégiques nos compétiteurs y
développent des stratégies hybride qui
s'inscrivent sous l'ombre portée de
leurs forces conventionnelles voir
nucléaire ce qui ne fait que renforcer
l'ambiguïté de ces menaces et brouille
les lignes entre guerre crise et paix
peut notamment citer la russie qui
appliquent ce mode d'action hybrides en
europe en afrique et au moyen orient
ses activités au pac nous oblige à
accroître nos capacités de renseignement
pour les déceler les caractériser et les
attribuer et nous conduisent donc à
renouveler nos postures pour prendre en
compte ces évolutions du jeu
international proche de nous sur les
flancs nord et est de l'europe la russie
développe depuis plusieurs années une
stratégie de défiance afin de maîtriser
son environnement proche
ces démonstrations de force se
multiplient à mesure que ses capacités
militaires
se renouvelle la russie s'est par
ailleurs imposé comme l'un de nos
principaux compétiteurs stratégique au
sud de la méditerranée au levant et en
afrique où elle cherche à sécuriser ses
implantations ou où elle n'hésite pas à
contester notre action ainsi que le
modèle français en s'appuyant sur des
acteurs non étatiques et sur des
manoeuvres de désinformation parmi ces
compétiteurs stratégique au sud de la
méditerranée ont compté vous l'avez
mentionné monsieur le président aussi la
turquie la turquie qui a été ces
derniers mois un acteur déstabilisant
perturbateurs qui a mené une politique
extérieure offensive et agressive
notamment par l'organisation de
campagnes de prospection gazière en
méditerranée orientale
escorté par de nombreux navires de
guerre la turquie cherche à s'imposer
par la force et par le fait accompli en
violant l'embargo sur les armes en libye
ou bien en s'immisçant dans le conflit
au haut karabakh où elle a apporté un
appui décisif à l'azerbaïdjan face à
l'arménie enfin et ce n'est pas le
moindre
la chine avance ses pions elle le fait
partout où elle le peut dans le monde
pour atteindre son objectif qui est de
se hisser au rang de première puissance
mondiale d'ici 2049 sur les routes de la
soie en indo pacifique en afrique en
arctique et jusque dans nos territoires
outre-mer
la chine investit massivement et étend
sa présence elle n'hésite plus à imposer
son propre système de valeurs et à
bafouer les règles internationales
notamment celles de la libre circulation
dans les airs et sur les mers il ya
d'ailleurs depuis le 1er février une loi
qui autorise les garde-côtes chinois a
employé des armes en vue de contraindre
les navires
étrangers à quitter les réseaux qui sont
revendiquées par la chine dans le
détroit de formose les avions chinois
réalisent régulièrement des incursions
dans l'espace aérien qui est contrôlé
par taïwan
toutes ces stratégies de puissance
s'appuie sur des dynamiques de
réarmement et cela malgré la pandémie
on estime ainsi que les budgets de
défense ont atteint en 2020 dans le
monde
1830 milliards de dollars ce qui
représente une progression par rapport à
2010 9 de près de 4% 3 9 % exactement
et c'est d'autant plus impressionnant
lorsqu'on sait que en 2019 le montant
total des budgets de la défense à
l'échelle mondiale avait déjà augmenté
de 4% ce qui était à l'époque considéré
comme la plus forte progression de toute
la décennie
ces augmentations sont naturellement
tiré par la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis ces deux pays ont vu
leurs budgets de défense augmenté pour
la chine de 5,2 pour cent et pour les
états unis de 6,3 pour cent les états
unis représentent à eux seuls plus de
40% 40,3 % des dépenses mondiales avec
738 milliards de dollars et la chine en
représente 10,6 pour cent
avec 208 milliards de dollars il y a
évidemment de la part de la chine une
volonté très forte de remettre en cause
la puissance des états unis et nous
voyons des concurrents se développer
dans tous les domaines que ce soit la
compétition commerciale jusqu'à la
rivalité militaire la chine est ainsi
devenue au troisième trimestre 2020 le
premier partenaire de l'union européenne
au plan commercial
là et a doublé pour la première fois les
états unis ce qui est la conséquence
directe de l'épidémie de kobe 19 nos
importations en provenance de la chine
ont augmenté de 4 et demi pour cent par
rapport à 2010 neuf notamment dans les
domaines médicaux électroniques
c'est très révélateur de notre
dépendance envers la chine que nous
devons absolument réduire en particulier
dans les domaines que je qualifierais de
critiques
je pourrais citer l'exemple de notre
dépendance en minerais critique en
terres rares que nous importons de chine
et qui sont indispensables à la
fabrication de matériels de défense du
rafale aux drones en passant par les
équipements de télécommunications et les
batteries mobiles de nos soldats
cet enjeu d'accès aux ressources
constituent un sujet très important pour
nos armées et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai voulu que soit au coeur de
notre stratégie énergétique de défense
malgré ses efforts pour développer le
recyclage et l'éco-conception l'union
européenne importe entre 75 à 100 % des
matières premières dont elle a besoin
comme le cobalt le nickel le lithium ou
le graphite naturelles qui sont utilisés
pour la fabrication des batteries
électriques
ce contexte stratégique
certes très sombre nous faut pas non
plus le regarder avec fatalité car nous
avons les moyens d'agir
nous avons des forces armées très
performante très entraînés et qui se
perfectionnent chaque jour pour rester à
la pointe des combats qui émergent
je pense par exemple monsieur le
président en exercice
aster auquel le président de la rippe
astérix pardon munster astérix le bien
nommé auquel le président de la
république a assisté vendredi dernier
qui est le tout premier exercice spatial
où nous avons simulé une attaque de nos
satellites et puis je pense aussi à un
autre exercice dont je voudrais vous
révéler maintenant les grandes lignes
qui a été menée le 13 mars dernier c'est
à dire la semaine dernière puisque les
forces armées françaises ont conduit un
exercice inédit de contre terrorisme en
méditerranée au large de la crète alors
il faut imaginer une prise d'otages sur
un navire commercial des terroristes ils
prennent le contrôle d'un navire et qui
en font une base de tir sur l'aude
voilà pour le scénario qui a mobilisé
toute la palette du haut du spectre de
nos moyens terrestres navals et aériens
en seulement quelques heures des
commandos marines ont été projetés par
avion sur zone avec une embarcation
légère d'assaut des rafale et des
hélicoptères caracal ont décollé de
france pour rejoindre le navire sous le
contrôle des terroristes à 2000
kilomètres de nos bases et se sont
engagés directement dans sa libération
cette manoeuvre a mobilisé 450
militaires des soldats de l'armée terre
des aviateurs des bâtiments de la marine
qui opèrent régulièrement dans cette
zone ainsi que d'importants moyens de
commandement et de contrôle
l'assaut a été bref grâce à la très
forte réactivité de nos forces et à la
capacité projection de nos armées avec
cet exercice au fond nous portons un
message sous notre vigilance française
et européenne ce message c'est que la
méditerranée ne sera jamais un espace de
non droit
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
seulement trois nations dans le monde
sont capables de conduire une telle
opération et la france est l'une d'elles
la france a la volonté de participer à
la préservation de la sécurité et de la
stabilité
et du bassin méditerranéen aux côtés de
ses alliés en projetant à longue
distance ses moyens d'intervention et en
mettant en oeuvre son savoir faire
exceptionnel la france montre qu'elle a
les moyens de se défendre avec ses
alliés car oui nous avons les moyens
mais nous devons le faire ensemble
c'est essentiel pour ne pas subir de
déclassement stratégiques le
renforcement de l'autonomie stratégique
européenne et la solution pour faire
face à ces nombreux défis et ce en bonne
intelligence avec l'otan évidemment car
pour avoir une alliance atlantique forte
il faut aussi une europe forte
cette europe forte c'est d'abord une
erreur et une europe que je qualifierais
de terrain la force takouba que nous
opérationnaliser en ce moment au sahel
est une grande réussite sur ce plan de
nombreux militaires issus des forces
spéciales de différents pays européens
combattent quotidiennement côte à côte
contre le terrorisme et j'aurai
l'occasion de m'entretenir prochainement
à ce sujet avec mes homologues suédois
tchèques estonien un sikh italien et
avec des représentants d'autres pays qui
réfléchisse à nous rejoindre
l'engagement des européens au sahel va
évidemment bien au delà de takouba ils
sont très nombreux au sein de
l'opération barkan ainsi que dans les
missions de l'union européenne et des
nations unies
ainsi de plus en plus d'européens
s'engage pour lutter contre l'expansion
de ces mouvements terroristes qui
menacent directement le territoire
européen
et c'est une excellente nouvelle que
l'europe osent s'élever pour défendre
ses intérêts son territoire et ses
citoyens
cette dynamique européenne ou la forge
ont tous les jours davantage grâce à
l'initiative européenne
intervention la présence maritime
coordonnées qui sera prochainement
expérimentés dans le golfe de guinée où
la piraterie reste malheureusement
prégnante et qui fait l'objet d'un
pillage de ses ressources procède
exactement de la même logique
elle permettra de renforcer notre
culture d'engagement en commun tout en
défendant le principe fondamental de
liberté de circulation sur les mers
cette europe forte dont je parle c'est
aussi une europe industriels et
innovante
le renforcement de notre
interopérabilité se fera par le
développement de capacités communes et
par la réduction de notre dépendance
technologique et industrielle
aujourd'hui nous devons mener à bien les
projets capacitaire en cours avec
l'allemagne vous l'avez rappelé je pense
bien entendu comme vous oscars omg cs
mais également aux tigres avec l'espagne
et à l'euro drones avec l'italie pour ce
qui concerne le scaf avec ma collègue
madame cruise 40 bioware nous avons
demandé aux industriels de poursuivre
leurs discussions pour aboutir à un
accord concernant le démonstrateur de
l'avion c'est une phase essentielle et
une phase qui doit absolument tenir
compte des grands principes que nous
avions acté en 2017
c'est à dire l'identification de
responsable pour chaque chantier du
programme ainsi que le principe du
meilleur athlète c'est un principe sur
lequel on ne peut pas transiger
on ne peut pas pour nos militaires pour
les jeunes ingénieurs ou techniciens qui
s'engageront dans ce projet mais aussi
pour nos concitoyens car nous devons
être absolument certains que c'est bien
la performance qui guide notre choix
quand il s'agit de notre défense et que
nos militaires seront équipés du
meilleur armement possible
cette europe forte c'est également une
europe stratège capable de nouer des
partenariats forts qui lui permettront
d'affirmer sa place sur la scène
internationale et c'est enfin une europe
solidaire et résiliente capable de mieux
se défendre face aux tentatives
extérieur de division ou
d'affaiblissement pour construire cette
europe forte nous avons évidemment
besoin d'être plus forts au plan
national et cela implique de poursuivre
les efforts de remonter en puissance de
nos armées que nous mettons en oeuvre
depuis plus de trois ans maintenant je
crois que nous pouvons avoir
collectivement la satisfaction de dire
que nous sommes sur la bonne voie
le strict respect de la loi de
programmation militaire en est la preuve
en 2020 les investissements d'équipement
de défense se sont élevées à 28
milliards 100 millions d'euros on estime
qu'avec un million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires réalisés dans le domaine de
la défense
on génère entre sept et huit emplois
sans compter le domaine du bâtiment et
travaux publics et des infrastructures
ainsi l'évolution de la ressource
budgétaire prévu en lpm créerait environ
25000 emplois directs supplémentaires
d'ici à 2022 et jusqu'à 70 milles à
l'horizon 2025
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
ces dépenses profite à tous
une industrie de défense performante ce
sont des emplois pour les français est
désarmé plus forte des armées fortes
sont des français protégés et ce en
toute circonstance nous pourrons
d'ailleurs lors de vos questions
évoquées peut-être plus en détail notre
récente participation aux opérations
coup de poing en termes de vaccination
qui ont été menées en france ou bien ou
au soutien particulier que nous
apportons aux outre mer pour faire face
à la crise sanitaire
dans cet environnement stratégique
dégrader la vitalité la force et
l'agilité de nos armées seront
essentiels pour garantir la sécurité la
protection nos intérêts de la france et
des français
merci beaucoup de votre attention et je
suis à votre disposition pour répondre à
vos questions et complétée le cas
échéant certain temps merci madame la
ministre pour ses premières précisions
je vais tout de suite passé la parole
aux différents intervenants nous avons
quinze collègues qui souhaite vous
interroger je vous propose de passer par
cinq questions par cinq questions ce qui
va permettre de rendre le débat un peu
plus actif et on va commencer par cédric
perrin merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
même la ministre nous avons examiné les
réponses ci ont été adressées au
questionnaire du rapporteur défense de
la commission je dois vous dire que je
ne comprends pas le choix qui est fait
pour faire simple un tiers des questions
reçoivent une réponse
un tiers des questions réponses très
soif une réponse partielle et un tiers d
autres réponses sont des réponses qui
n'en sont pas dans certains cas il
s'agit d'informations prises dans le
bleu budgétaire parfois même moins
le président est encore bon l'a dit le
sénat a voté la loi de programmation
militaire à 95%
pourquoi du coup avoir fait le choix de
nous tenir à l'écart à aucun moment la
décision de ne pas faire la loi
d'actualisation qui étaient écrites dans
la lpm n'a été annoncée et encore moins
expliqué en décembre encore au moment du
budget vous nous avez disiez que la
décision était n'était pas prise dès la
fin de l'été pourtant les signes les
premiers signes laissaient présager du
contraire
pendant que la vga et les armées
devaient travailler fin 2020 a actualisé
la loi de programmation militaire sous
le radar c'est à dire hors des yeux du
parlement on nous laissait encore
envisager qu'une loi interviendrait
peut-être aujourd'hui vous êtes engagés
dans la 2 pm dans l'ajustement annuel de
la programmation militaire
nous vous demandons de nous dire quels
sont les en sont les enjeux principaux
pourquoi finalement ne pas avoir choisi
la transparence avec le parlement avec
le sénat qui vous a toujours soutenu
depuis votre prise de fonction de
président l'a rappelé à de nombreuses
reprises pourquoi ne pas nous avoir
nous avoir dit fin 2020 voilà j'ai
demandé une loi d'actualisation mais
j'en ai je n'ai pas eu satisfaction nous
allons donc procéder à une actualisation
non législative voilà quels sont les
enjeux voilà quels sont les choix et
voilà quelles sont les priorités
les crédits ne permettront pas de faire
de tout faire et voilà ce qu'il faut
faire en priorité
on est tous ici des élus on nous aurions
parfaitement compris ce discours de
réalité au lieu de cela vous avez fait
le choix de ne pas communiquer de ne pas
nous donner l'information et
malheureusement les réponses que nous
avons reçues un autre questionnaire
semble aller dans le même sens alors
faudrait que quelques réponses
supplémentaires soit arrivé ce soir donc
nous verrons en les analysant 6 e s vont
dans le sens de ce que nous attendions
mais madame la ministre vous êtes
pleinement engagé dans votre mission
nous avons toujours saluer votre
mobilisation vos efforts pour nos armées
pour notre défense et vous comprenez
bien que nous aussi nous devons remplir
notre mission constitutionnelle et cela
passe notamment par le recueil et
l'analyse des informations et la
vigilance sur la trajectoire budgétaire
de la lpm je tenais à exprimer notre
incompréhension mais aussi notre
mobilisation pour la suite de ce travail
sur l'actualisation de la note
programmation militaire et sur l'a2 pm
et j'ai deux questions
si je me permets la première concerne
évidemment fin de questions sur le ngf
sur les droits de propriété
intellectuelle parce que nous avons
auditionné ce matin les gens de chez
airbus et la semaine dernière les gens
de chez dassault donc ont qu un peu
confronter les points de vue des uns et
des autres sur les droits de propriété
actuelle du ngf notamment tout le
background que les allemands et les
espagnols exige aujourd'hui que comptez
vous faire pour protéger ses
savoir-faire français est toujours sur
le ngf quelle assurance avez-vous de la
prise en compte de la mission nucléaire
et aéronaval on y beaucoup de choses
dans la presse en ce moment dans le
dessein de l'avion devant le refus le
refus semble-t-il assez systématique ces
derniers temps de l'allemagne et de
l'espagne de les voir de le voir mis en
oeuvre merci beaucoup merci cédric
hélène conway
on est à chacun de bien calibrer ses
propos telle sorte que tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer
dans le temps qui nous est imparti ln
oui merci président le mien est centré
sur une question madame la ministre vous
ai parlé d'une europe et d'une france
forte avec les meilleurs équipements
donc je vais vous ramener au programme
avec en effet des réponses que nous
avons que nous avons reçues et qui
confie siens qui confirme qu'il existe
des besoins nouveaux et que ceci bien
sûr devant être financé à enveloppe
constante donc comment financer ces
besoins ça sans ralentir d'autres
programmes c'est quand même
mathématiquement compliqué voire
impossible
c'est pourquoi nous interrogeons sur les
arbitrages réalisés ou à réaliser
certains grands projets financièrement
très lourds seront probablement autant
que tu as he is et parle du
renouvellement de la dissuasion
nucléaire
mais cela c'est après 2023 le scaf nous
en parlons beaucoup en ce moment le
porte avions de nouvelle génération qui
a été annoncé par le président dont nous
craignons des effets finalement de
ponction sinon d'éviction sur d'autres
programmes
d'autant que l'apparition de nouvelles
menaces génère des besoins capacitaires
et vous l'avez rappelé dans le domaine
spatial et cyber ou encore dans la lutte
anti drones nous avons douze nouveaux
rafales qui ont été commandés récemment
pour compenser les effets de l'expo
grecque et s'agissant de l'armée de
terre le traitement des obsolescences du
char leclerc sera coûteux mais si l'on
veut être prêt pour la haute intensité
réaliser l'ambition de 1037 remise à
niveau devra se faire sans effet
d'éviction sur d'autres aspects du
programme scorpion en programmes à
effets majeurs les opérations à hauteur
d'homme doivent aussi bien sûr être
préservé les évolutions de la
programmation sont naturels dans un
contexte stratégique fluctuant
s'agissant de programmes industriels
lourds et technologiquement complexe
mais ce dont nous avons besoin
la ministre c'est de la clarté d'une
certaine visibilité puisque pour
l'instant la revoyure devait nous la
fournir mais nous avons simplement que
des réponses à un questionnaire donc à
combien estimez vous les besoins
nouveaux
quels sont les programmes sanctuariser
et ceux pour lesquels vous envisager un
ralentissement quels sont les impacts de
ces arbitrages sur la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs de la lpm à l'horizon 2025
jour merci merci
andré gueule merci président madame la
ministre je voulais vous interroger sur
la santé des militaires et à deux
niveaux le premier c'est concerne leur
sécurité sur le territoire national la
semaine dernière un homme qui avait
commencé à élaborer un projet d'attentât
contre les militaires en misant
semble-t-il la citadelle de lille a été
arrêté cet épisode confirme que les
militaires demeure une cible privilégiée
du terrorisme comment il va vous évaluez
vous la menace de nos forces sur ce
territoire
je souligne que les effectifs de
sentinelle vont être réduits premier
militaire avec un niveau d'alerté du
plan vigipirate repas c'est l'urgence
attentats du niveau de haut niveau
risque d'attentats mais n'est-ce pas
prématuré de baisser un peu la garde
ce choix est il compensait par renfort
des moyens des services de renseignement
quant au second niveau concerne la
protection cette fois-ci sanitaires de
notre armée comment se déroule la
stratégie vaccinale au sein de la
défense on se souvient de l'épisode
malheureux décontamination à bord du
porte avions charles de gaulle
quel bilan fais-tu ou de la pandémie de
son éventuel impact sur les capacités
opérationnelles de nos forces
je vous remercie
merci andré olivier cigolotti merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
dans le cadre de la révision de la revue
stratégique nous avait parfaitement
décrit les risques de conflit de haute
intensité et à ce titre le programme 178
et le coeur de la mission défense
puisqu'il porte sur la préparation et
l'emploi de nos militaires vous
comprendrez donc nos demandes dans ce
domaine soit assez précise j'aurais pour
ma part de questions la première porte
sur les crédits dédiés à l'entretien
programmé du matériel une bosse
budgétaire d'environ 900 millions non
inscrits sur les trois premières années
les le pm semble se profiler
vous nous direz quel est votre vision
sur ce point s'y ajoutent bien sûr des
dépenses conjoncturelles je pense
notamment à la réparation de la perle
pour 70 millions d'euros et le surcoût
induit par la livraison des deux rafale
destinés à la grèce
d'autres facteurs sont structurels tels
que la multiplication des opex et
l'usure conséquente des matériels qui en
découlent en exécution les dépenses ont
d'ailleurs largement supérieur aux
prévisions en loi de finances initiale
puisqu'on parle de montants proches du
milliard
depuis le début de la lpm madame la
ministre et l'enveloppent des crédits
alloués à le pm peut-elle être à changer
dans ces conditions c'est ma première
question
deuxième question nous avions sollicité
sur les engagements découlant des
sommets de l'otan que se traduisent que
ces derniers se traduisent par une
augmentation conséquente de l' enveloppe
de la lpm or la réassurance et nos
engagements vis-à-vis de nos alliés
doivent être inévitablement financé et
ce sans obérer la programmation bien sûr
la lpm
des propositions ont été mis sur la
table par le secrétaire général de
l'otan quels sont selon vous les
incidences qui pourrait prospérer et le
dispositif protégeant l'enveloppent de
la lpm pourrait-il dans ces conditions
être appliquée merci merci olivier
dernier intervenant pour ce premier
groupe jean marc todeschini
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre tout d'abord j'aimerais
rappeler cela dit le président tombons
tout à l'heure c'est qu'on est là pour
vous aider en clair même si on peut être
un peu embêtant dans nos questions je
crois que l'intérêt qu'on manifeste
c'est surtout d'aider nos forces armées
d'aidé de vous aider alors j'ai eu un
prof âge dit ça parce que tout
simplement je vais reprendre s'est dit
cédric vous avez décidé de ne pas
recourir à l'article 7 de la lpm
on ne passons pas son actualisation dans
la représentation nationale
je me suis demandé pourquoi est ce qu'il
y ait un danger en risque budgétaire
en effet les crises sanitaires et
économiques font que finalement le
budget de la défense va être inscrit
dans la trajectoire des 2%
mécaniquement et donc du pib est-ce que
là bercy on pourrait considérer que les
efforts budgétaires sont déjà rempli les
objectifs politiques ne sont pas
remplies ils ne peuvent pas l'être
vous aviez dit
lorsque vous avez présenté là la loi de
programmation militaire
mais vous aviez insisté lourdement sur
la cohérence en termes de réponses aux
enjeux identifiés par la revue
stratégique de 2017
la revue stratégique a récemment et
entre l'actualiser et vous ne lit que ce
ne sera pas le cas de la lpm devant le
parlement
alors pourquoi comment garantir que les
efforts budgétaires nécessaires seront à
la hauteur des ambitions de la mpm 2010
9 2025
en un mot est ce qu'on n'est pas dans
une situation où le médecin pose un bon
diagnostic mais qu'il n'aura pas les
moyens de soigner son patient alors
quelle est la méthode que vous nous
proposez puisque gilles bien c'est pas
du tout il n'a pas qu'un sait comment ça
va se passer quelle et quelles sont les
solutions pour que cela puisse
réellement approché avec une approche
rationnelle en tout cas de la lpm que
nous allons tous adopté pratiquement je
crois que vaut la parole à toussoter
alors quelques questions dont la lpm il
y avait bien sûr des niveaux de
recrutement de personnel ce que vous
pouvez nous dire où on en est à ce stade
et puis quels sont les moyens quels sont
les capacités du ministère à attirer les
meilleurs profils d inscrire dans la
durée
j'aurais aussi une question mais la
branche je la passe et ce que vous
pourriez nous dire où on en est avec
deux logiciels sur ce seul puisque l'on
voit été catastrophe mais c'est vieux
c'est raza remonte à quelque temps est
ce que vraiment ce logiciel ce nouveau
logiciel sera opérationnel et des
soldats seront ils rassurent et enfin
j'aurai revenir sur l' enquête publiée
tout récemment
mais je préfère écouter la voix des
ministres sur le sujet là c'est
médiapart bien sûr je ne fais pas
confiance
toujours aux sources journalistiques
c'est un jeu sujet un sujet qu'il pût
qui pourrait bien être réchauffé je sais
que le ministère a répondu clairement
furent suscite ce sujet est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire quels sont les moyens
et quelles sont les mesures que vous
entendez prendre suite à ces révélations
des révélations qui était connu c'était
connu par le passé est en tout cas quels
sont les moyens que vous avez pour la
prévention et des sanctions éventuelles
voilà madame la ministre un premier
train de questions et merci donc de vos
réponses et de leur précision merci
beaucoup monsieur le président donc je
commencerai d'abord par la question de
l'actualisation de notre loi de
programmation militaire sur le sénateur
perrin vous avez attaqué fort en disant
que nous n'avions pas répondu
convenablement à vos questions j'en
avait parfaitement conscience c'est la
raison pour laquelle
je me suis permis de remettre de manière
un peu solennel devant vous tous un
document qui je l'espère permettra de
progresser dans la qualité et des
réponses qui sont fournis je crois que
nous sommes tous autour
en tout cas dans cette salle de très
bonne foi de très bonnes volontés nous
voulons tous que nos armées puissent
bénéficier de des engagements qui ont
été pris très solennellement dans cette
loi de programmation militaire que vous
avez bien voulu très largement voté
personne n'a de doute là dessus
et donc ce que nous voulons c'est
avancer alors moi je n'ai rien caché à
personne je suis et certains d'entre
vous dans cette salle savent quels sont
les devoirs d'un membre du gouvernement
j'ai fait valoir les arguments que je
croyais devoir faire valoir et nous
avons débattu et une décision a été
prise cette décision vous la connaissez
elle a été annoncée par le président de
la république lorsque elle a été prise
c'est à dire au moment des voeux aux
armées et le président de la république
a clairement indiqué qu'il souhaitait
que nous trouvions les bonnes modalités
pour que le parlement les parlementaires
puissent être associés à cet exercice
donc la séance que nous avons
aujourd'hui est la première étape
peut-être d'une série mais là je ne veux
pas me substituer à vos initiatives
c'est vous que c'est vous qui en
déciderai donc et vous savez combien je
me plie avec plaisir et volontiers à ces
séances qui je crois en pour vocation
d'éclairer la représentation nationale
et qui sont essentielles pour que chacun
est la conviction et la preuve aussi que
les engagements pris sont tenus donc je
ne voudrais pas revenir sur le passé
vous savez tous que cela n'a pas été
toujours le cas loin s'en faut
nous sommes maintenant dans une période
depuis 2010 c'est tout
le budget même de la mission défense n'a
cessé de croître
exactement comme cela était prévu en
niveau c'est presque 7 milliards de plus
par rapport à 2010 est en masse c'est 18
milliards de plus au moment où on se
parle je ne parle même pas des des
annuités qui sont à venir
c'était tout à fait indispensable et ce
plus important sans doute encore c'est
que nous exécutons cela de façon je
crois très conforme et nous aurons
certainement dans le cadre d une de la
loi de finances rectificative a vérifié
ensemble que la gestion l'exécution 2020
est conforme à la loi de finances
initiale malgré les perturbations très
importantes qui ont été provoqués par
par la crise sanitaire
donc je ne reviens pas sur la méthode je
pense que chaque assemblée l'assemblée
nationale d'un côté le sénat de l'autre
définiront souverainement les modalités
par lesquelles elles souhaitent où il
souhaite que nous puissions travailler
ensemble en tout cas sachez que nous
sommes à votre disposition et que ces
questionnaires sont comment dire la mort
d'un débat et que s'il ya des questions
complémentaires nous restons évidemment
à votre entière disposition pour y
répondre
en ce qui concerne maintenant le
le ska puisque vous aviez je crois
monsieur le sénateur de question pour ce
qui concerne la l'enjeu c'est que vous
avez des auditions et notamment que les
industriels sont venus ou faire un point
sur ce sujet la question de la propriété
intellectuelle est l'objet même des
discussions qui sont en cours
moi je voudrais vous dire que on a quand
même réussi à trouver des solutions pour
d'autres programmes de coopération et de
manière assez récente sur l'euro drones
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi ce qui a pu
fonctionner pour leurs drones ne
fonctionnerait pas pour le scaf
évidemment nous serons très vigilants à
ce que la propriété intellectuelle qui a
été comment dire constitué année après
année par des industriels talentueux ne
soit pas considérée comme facilement
acquise en revanche la propriété
intellectuelle qui sera construite par
la coopération évidemment aura vocation
à être partagés en ce qui concerne
l'émission nucléaire et le comment dire
la version aéronavale du scaf il est
clair que
les investissements que nous allons
consentir dans le cadre du skal devront
être parfaitement cohérent avec nos
besoins dans le domaine de la dissuasion
ça c'est une évidence et
aujourd'hui rien dans nos discussions
actuelles ne laissent présager de
difficultés pour intégrer ses
spécificités
donc je vous propose de donner
rendez-vous très prochainement pour
faire un point sur l'aboutissement de
ces discussions qui ont lieu entre les
industriels et dans le respect des
principes que j'ai rappelé dans mon
propos liminaire ce qu'il paraît
extrêmement important en ce qui concerne
maintenant les questions relatives au
programme 146,1 à sénatrice où vous avez
tout à fait raison de dire que oui des
besoins en nouveaux émergent est
d'ailleurs le l'exercice que nous avons
conduit un sur l'actualisation de notre
revue stratégique montre la voie qui
nous convient d'emprunter pour essayer
de de mettre nos armées les plus à mêmes
en situation de répondre à ces nouvelles
menaces pour alors comment est-ce qu'on
peut le faire à enveloppe constante
ça c'est notre c'est effectivement notre
notre travail et notre défi ce que je
voudrais souligner mais que vous
connaissez parfaitement c'est que le
mystère de la désarmer et la mission
défense peuvent s'appuyer et c'est sans
doute notre particularité historique sur
des lois de programmation pluriannuelle
parce que nos programmes sont des
programmes de long terme et que nous
avons besoin
s'agissant d'investissement qui engage
dans la durée d'avoir cette visibilité
pluriannuelle et le fait que ces
programmes soient plus réelle mais elle
nous est comment dire une est un outil
qui nous permet année après année dans
le cadre des révisions que nous faisons
dans ce travail date de pm qui est le
nom technique qui est donnée à ceux cet
exercice
comment dire de de vérification que nous
tenons bien les trajectoires et
d'identification des programmes qui
peuvent être amenées pour des raisons
très variés à prendre un certain retard
à un moment donné permettent donc de
redonner des marges de manoeuvre sur
d'autres sur d'autres aspects c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous a permis souvenez
vous en en 2020 dans le cadre de la
crise sanitaire de pouvoir identifier
des moyens à enveloppe constante pour
contribuer au plan de soutien et
aéronautique c'est un exemple ça ne veut
pas dire que nous allons renoncer à des
investissements qui atteindront un peu
plus tard mais ça permet d'être certain
que tous les euros qui nous sont
consentis après année après année plutôt
que de créer des reports sur le futur et
bien ont un impact immédiat direct au
moment où par ailleurs notre économie
nos industries en ont besoin donc cet
exercice de pm il est extrêmement
important pour nous permettre
d'identifier les marges de manoeuvre
dont nous disposons à l'instant t pour
pouvoir réel ou est temporairement sur
les programmes qui sont en situation de
pouvoir avancer plus vite des crédits
qui sont normalement
à louer à d'autres programmes et tout ça
évidemment se fait sous un temps sous le
contrôle étroit du parlement et du
ministère des finances
donc je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de de
crainte à avoir sur les la manière dont
nous nous pilotons ses crédits et
comment nous pouvons y identifier des
moyens supplémentaires à l'intérieur
d'une enveloppe qui elle est finie nous
le savons c'est seule enveloppe de la
loi de programmation militaire est de
l'ordre de finances annuelles
alors oui nous avons
identifié un certain nombre de besoins
nouveaux vous avez mentionné le fait que
nous ne pouvons pas toujours tout
prévoir par exemple la bonne nouvelle de
la vente de rafale à la grèce ça ça
n'était pas attendue nous en réjouissons
la conséquence de cette export c'est que
nous devons évidemment remplacé les
rafales que l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace va transférer à l'armée de
l'air grecque
donc nous avons je crois vous l'avoir
dit obtenu l'assurance que les produits
cession de ces de ses rafales seront
entièrement restituée au mystère aux
mystères de désarmer donc ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle
devant nous nous avons en effet un
programme lourd mais qui est pour le
coup qui était connu qui était celui de
d'irene la rénovation des blocs l'air
donc nous avons à la fois des choses qui
était prévu nous avions prévu que nous
lancerions des programmes en coopération
tels que le ska foulem gcs nous avions
prévu que nous travaillions sur un
porte-avions de nouvelle génération
pendant cette loi de programmation
militaire dont tout ça ce sont des
objets nouveaux pour à horizon de 20 ou
30 ans dont nous démarrons les études
maintenant mais comment dire la loi de
programmation ne les découvre pas elle
les avait intégré dès le départ alors
naturellement les les investissements
essentiels liés à ces programmes relève
plutôt d'une loi de programmation futurs
sages
c'est l'évidence mais nous n'avons pas
découvert en tant que besoin à nouveau
les crédits d'études dont nous avons
besoin en ce moment pour pouvoir lancer
ses programmes et naturellement les
besoins nouveaux que nous avons
identifiées sur le programme 146 ne
doivent pas nous conduire à sacrifier
les investissements que nous avons
souhaité ensemble consentir à hauteur
d'homme parce que la hauteur d'homme
reste la priorité absolue en tout cas
c'est ma priorité absolue
question maintenant concernant
sentinelle d'abord et d'une façon
générale la protection la protection de
nos soldats
alors vous avez sans doute remarqué que
nous sommes en train d'adapter notre
dispositif vigipirate qui avait été
relevé au niveau maximum après les
attentats du mois de la fin du mois
d'octobre
donc nous sommes comme toujours eu
en situation d'adapter ce dispositif
sentinelle qui n'est pas un dispositif
ni statique ni figé à l'évolution de la
menace elle-même donc puisque le niveau
de vigipirate a été replacé au niveau
de sécurité renforcées eh bien nous
adaptons également sentinelle alors ça
ne peut pas dire que nous nous
désengageons de sentinelle mais nous
modifions la part des militaires qui
sont mobilisées en permanence sur le
terrain et puis celle qui est
mobilisable de façon extrêmement rapide
pour pouvoir apporter un renfort si ce
renfort est nécessaire donc nous
ramenons à trois mille 3000 militaires
le nombre de soldes militaires engagés
en permanence
et puis nous avons une capacité de 4000
hommes qui peut être engagées sont
extrêmement court préavis
donc sentinelle continue à protéger
défendre et dissuader contre la menace
terroriste alors autres et volet de la
question c'est comment est-ce que nous
protégeons nos militaires dans le cadre
de la pandémie
donc nous avons on se souvient tous
en effet deux des difficultés que nous
avions pu rencontrer au printemps si
bien que lorsque
nous avons
travailler sur la politique de
vaccination du mystère des armées qui
est une politique est évidemment
parfaitement cohérente avec la stratégie
vaccinale nationale nous avons été
amenés à prendre en compte un certain
nombre de particularités par exemple le
fait que le départ de l'équipage du
porte-avions charles-de-gaulle en
mission dans le cadre de chat mâle
nécessitait la vaccination de la
totalité de cet équipage et nous avons
également indiqué que nous avions
vacciner les équipages l'équipage qui
était parti en patrouille de snl on en
comprend les raisons elles sont
évidentes
la capacité à revenir en cas
d'apparition d'un cas positif est
extrêmement complexe
or ça ne signifie pas qu'il faille on
que nous puissions patiné tout le monde
en ce moment c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons eu cette approche
aussi sélectif que possible qui rezai
six nations à d
sonel extrêmement extrêmement ciblée
question maintenant concernant les
crédits consacrés à l'entretien
programmé du matériel cette question du
maintien en condition opérationnelle est
et centrale où vous vous souvenez des
débats que nous avons eus llp m parfois
on a peut être eu un peu trop tendance à
comment dire remédier à ces problèmes de
disponibilité en pratiquant la politique
de la fuite en avant et en investissant
tous caen en espérant investir dans les
matériels nouveaux
ce que nous essayons de faire c'est un
peu les deux c'est à dire à la fois
continuer d'investir dans du matériel
nouveau mais aussi prendre soin des
matériels dont nous disposons déjà et
qui sont parfois trop souvent
immobilisés par manque de pièces et
autres
[Musique]